touch le premier jour du procès vous
avez déclaré dans un communiqué ce que
vous aimiez encore johnny
oui c'est ce que c'est sur le cac et as
oui après tout ce qui s'est passé et sur
de vrais complètement
complètement
je laime ok ok je dis non c'est pour toi
cyril c'est du foutage de gueule total
c'est uniquement pour espérer une
négociation à l'amiable et qu'ils
acceptent une réduction des 10 millions
de dollars mais c'est scandaleux de sa
part elle l'a pourri depuis des années
elle a taillé en morceaux à l'audience à
la perdu maintenant elle lui dit je
t'aime alors franchement c'est nul elle
expliquait ne prendre pas l'addition des
jours et personnellement je les
comprends presque a pour elle johnny
depp faisait appel à des témoins qui
seraient six employés regarder ce
qu'elle dit de toyota
mais que peuvent-ils faire un jugement
comment aurait-il pu arriver une autre
conclusion que ça rhinos sont restés
assis dans ses 16 ils ont écouté plus de
trois semaines de témoignages
le témoignage en cessant de la part
d'employés payés
et vers la fin de gens au hasard saxe
est ce alors vous n'en voulez pas au
jury je ne leur en veux pas je les
comprends c'est un personnage aimé les
gens ont l'impression de connaître ça
fasse un acteur fantastique
comment ont-ils pu
après avoir entendu trois semaines et de
témoignages
disons que je n'étais pas une personne
crédible de ne pas croire le monde
remous qui sortaient de la bouche de
djerba
parce que dit on parlait du pirate des
caraïbes et qui me suis un petit peu le
pirate de dieu alors gagner ce qu'a dit
oui oui c'est là qu'on voit que c'est
une manipulatrice parce que d'un côté
elle dit bien sûr que les jurés ont reçu
des faux témoignages et donc du coup je
suis innocente et d'un autre côté elle
dit que johnny est fantastique et que
c'est une personnalité et voilà en fait
c'est une grosse manipe il à metz oui
c'est très malsain elle est peut-être
manipulatrice mais s'il était folle en
fait si psychiatriquement c'était
quelqu'un de fragile oui parce qu'en
fait moi je trouve qu'elle lit tout et
son contraire ne fait quelques temps
normal dit d'abord il ya des menteurs
ils ont tous menti c'est affreux j'en
peux plus du voyeurisme vote a dit tout
et son contraire elle est complètement
perdue elle a un pet au casque en fait
donc elle est plus être manipulatrice
mais je pense qu'elle a vraiment une
santé mentale qui est compliquée et je
pense que ça peut même c'est terminé
pour elle quand elle dit que le gros
problème c'est le traitement médiatique
dont elle a été victime notamment sur
les réseaux sociaux et pour elle le
nourrit ce truc là un jury la force est
en vue et pourraient être influencés dès
le moindre la dessiner au procès y avait
son psy d'ailleurs elle est suivi
psychologiquement elle à tripoli pas la
regarder ce qu'elle a dit amber
je pense que la grande majorité de ce
procès s'est joué sur les réseaux
sociaux
et à montrer
tout est parti en vrille à cause de ce
procès il jury n'est pas insensible à
cela et je pense que même pour le jury
le plus sérieux
il aurait été impossible de ne pas
tomber dessus vitesse et voyelles se
plaint du voyeurisme elle fait du
voyeurisme mais même en disant ça et
elle remet à nouveau une pièce dans la
machine pièce dans la machine non mais
comme elle fait appel
est là elle est en train de trouver des
thèmes le jury avait été influencé les
témoins étaient payés par johnny depp
voilà mais en fait ça va se passer ce
passera exactement la même chose au
procès en appel envers l'autiste en fait
c'est elle la vraie paix absolument
m'associant
aujourd'hui encore à le maintient ses
accusations devant bührer regardez
vous avez accepté le verdict
au collet comment respirer
intensifie s'il est ce que vous
maintenez votre témoignage est vite
accusations contre johnny depp de
violences conjugales
bien sûr sur mon lit de mort je m'en
tiendrais chaque détail était mon
témoignage
à la dé quoi
le
wii wheel la vraie star du procès c'est
l'avocate de johnny depp madame vazquez
la jeune épouse partiel est courtisé par
le monde entier mal à masquer est
absolument camille camille
est alors non il faut tout son cabinet
d' associer à votre calme dans son
cabinet je n'avais pas voulu il n'avait
pas voulu qu'elles deviennent associés
si l'asc est voilà est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui elle leur dit vous m'avez
méprisé je vais aller ailleurs elle peut
avoir mais le monde à ses pieds ou de
l'avocat vazquez comment une photo de
votre caisse parce que d'ailleurs il se
murmure que peut-être elle aurait une
relation avec johnny depp johnny depp
aujourd'hui voilà johnny depp
vanessa c'est madame basket
c'est quand tu sais pas faire cavaliers
seuls et guillaume sur l'annoncé non
messieurs et amber heard à l'arrêt coupe
à
l'homme le plus riche du monde oui maman
mais il va donner les dix bars à johnny
depp pu terminer et même pas venu
témoigner il devait venir alors
et veut pas s'afficher à l'airial avec
elle on abuse que oui c'est ben arfa qui
est belle aux
lots de masques
je trouve beau gosse
bon allez avec johnny depp c'est sûr
frère
madame basquaise à
saubusse célibataire mais vous me suivez
des dents je préfère madame basket squat
à thala beaucoup de danse éponymes des
panneaux
déjà m'a dépanné d'un service
[Rires]